めんちゃま
Hi こんにちは
ハジーポッターです　世の中には不思議なことが
たくさんある
魔法もそう　おばけもそう
においもまた不思議なにおいがあります
１年前くらいに動画で紹介した絶対ゲロが出る
魔法の瓶もまた魔法のアイテムの一つ。１年たった今でもそのにおいは健在。
今もにおいを嗅いじゃうとゲロがでちゃうんだ。
ほらね。あの…ほんとに…うっ…すごい
一年たった今でも全然におい嗅ぐだけで
ゲロ僕出ちゃうんですけど…　今回はこの強力な闇魔法に
対抗するために僕は光の魔法を考えました
今回シュークリームの皮が痛かったな
こちらエアソフィオ…エアソフィワ…
エアソフィア・ハイパー　無臭の消臭スプレーです
素晴らしい魔法のアイテムだとは思わないか？
気になるニオイを瞬間消臭。天然植物成分なので安心してご使用いただけます。
香りで紛らわすことなく、においそのものを分解し無臭化する
本物の消臭剤です。スゴっっっ！
病室等の不快臭とか下駄箱のにおいとかペットエリア
タバコの臭い・魚の臭い
いや、関係ねぇか。無臭の消臭スプレーってことはほんとに臭いを消す
分解する魔法のスプレーです。
ほんとににおいが…
と言うスプレーをとりあえず準備しました。もう一つ…
消臭B’z。このでかいビーズがたくさん入ってるんですけど、消臭…
大容量でしっかり消臭！　これはスプレーではなく物体です。
色々な嫌な臭いに対し消臭作用のある植物系消臭成分
などしっかり浸透させた消臭剤です。おーーーー
勝った　どうしようもない臭いなんですよ。ほんとにどうしようもないんですよ
もう臭い嗅ぐだけで
ほんとにあの…マジですごいんですよ臭いが
この闇の力を込めた魔法の
臭いのするあれと、全ての臭いを打ち消すこの光のアイテム。
今回はこの闇と光を撃ち合わせると
どっちが勝つのかと言う検証をしていきたいと思います。
いや～実にホグワーツっぽい実験ですね。　完全に魔法学校。
これでこの実験が成功すれば
臭い嗅ぐとゲロが出るこの瓶を永遠に消滅させることが可能かもしれません
そうなれば凄いです。ほんとに
しっかりしてると思います。臭いを匂いで誤魔化すと言うより
根本的に臭いを消すと言う消臭スプレーなんでその実力は間違いないと思います。
では、入れていきましょう。
終わり！また出ちゃった。ほんとにもう近寄りたくないんだよな。
待ってほんとにちょっと…一回ちょっと…
跳ね返ってね?!
あれ？あ、待ってこれ行けるぞ！
待ってハサミが…開かん…アカン…
誰かぁーーーー！助けてぇーーーー！
ハサミぃーーーーーー！
ありました。カットばさみ
ここで…
なんで俺の方…
これで相手を弱めてる瞬間にこう狙い撃ちするしか無い！
ぶち込んでみます！
やったか…
全部入りました。これで蓋をして
ちょっと時間を置いてみましょう。では、封印！
では、臭いを嗅ぐとゲロが出てしまう最強の液体vs
臭いを打ち消す最強のアイテム
この２つの戦いの結果がこの壺の中に入っています。
それでは臭いを嗅いで行きましょう
３・・・２・・・１・・・
あれ?!
えっ?!
オエッ